if a man does not love Solitude he will  not love freedom for it is only when he  is alone that he is really free  everyone takes the limits of his own  vision for the limits of the world  a pessimist is an optimist in full  possession of the facts  politeness is the human nature what  warmth is to wax  [Music]  youth is most beautiful undraped  in Action a great heart is the chief  qualification in work a great head  honor has not to be won it must only not  be lost  [Music]  Talent hits a Target no one else can hit  genius hits a Target no one else can see  [Music]  Ordinary People merely think how they  shall spend their time  a man of talent uses it  [Music]  one should use common words to say  uncommon things  hope is the confusion of the desire for  a thing with its probability  to overcome difficulties is to  experience the full Delight of existence  [Music]